he is future pro Football Hall of Famer
Steve Smith how are you Steve
hello coworker
I'm fine coworker what did you think of
the Michael Thomas cellphone celebration
Steve Howe soon as he went for the how
he knew what was going on so it was
pretty it was pretty funny you know some
people didn't like it
I know Troy was on there he didn't like
the original one he definitely didn't
like the tribute but I mean you got to
understand that's what those young guys
and that's what football and celebration
is all about just kind of have fun you
know some people prefer you to act like
you've been there before but as I know
hey at some point you will never be able
to score a touchdown every year so have
fun it's got nothing to do with fun I
love fun I love these touchdown
celebrations but when you know that
you're gonna get flagged for what you're
doing doesn't that worry you that's the
that's the issue I have for at the
moment - I mean the Rams are down 10 you
want to keep them down 10 yeah I agree
but I don't know it's tough because I'm
all about you know just kind of having
that kind of fun I get the penalty and
all that stuff I think one I think at
the end of the day they got to win and
let's be honest if that penalty was part
of the reason why they lost well they
didn't they didn't deserve it when they
gave me the life so that's kind of how I
look at it coach you know coach Peyton
probably didn't like it but you know at
the same time those guys are going I
mean my man putting up 12 12 sets is 211
yards he just went to work yeah I mean
he put the rush at on Marcus Peters
what's wrong with Marcus Peters do you
think Steve is there something what's
what's happened with him well what's
happening with him is one of the things
he always has been a guy who Gamble's
his football intelligence is off the
roof out of the out of the building he
knows how to play he watches film but
what we're seeing right now with
him and is exposed he lacks the
athleticism and he's not a really strong
guy you know like Jalen Ramsay is a
strong guy he's tall he's strong when
you look at Marcus Peters he's not
strong he's not quick and when you put
all those things together in your
gambler you get you get P I penalties
because now you're just trying to
survive right and this is just clearly
for me
why receiver evaluates will evaluate in
a corner he is a guy when you go back to
Kansas City he didn't follow he stayed
on one side with the Rams they have him
following and it's not working out he's
getting exposed people are going at him
he people used to go away from him now
people are going at him he is not the
guy in and you know less less meat and
and and Sean McVeigh came out and said
they don't like that people saying
they're all in let me tell you a secret
about the Los Angeles Rams they traded
for to lead a mortgage Peters because do
you see the guys that are the backups
that are covering people or attempting
to cover people it's not going very well
the second touchdown ala camara call out
of backfield three guys were there one
guy Joyner was trying to make the tackle
the other guy hope the other guy maybe
tackle another guy just close design
they on it back half in the secondary or
not a good bunch of guys and we're
seeing that week in and week out so do
you prescribe to the theory that the
Saints just not only exposed the Rams
but passed them in the NFC race right
now you have to because that was a
playoff game it was a playoff atmosphere
and it was a and it had implications of
home-field advantage and playoff
position and you saw what we saw is two
defenses who are struggling but every
great offense right now currently in the
2018 season the great officers have poor
defenses and the really good defenses
have terrible
so an in that regard Steve Smith senior
is the most complete team the Los
Angeles chargers because I mean they got
the running game they got the
quarterback they've got some receivers
they've got they seem to be they've got
a defense they just don't have a kicker
they already by the way they released
Caleb Sturgis today I can't they're like
Alabama they can't figure out how to get
a kicker so is that what you say you
think the Chargers are the most complete
team in the NFL through through nine
weeks I wouldn't say they're the most
complete team but they seem to have
everything on both sides of the ball
they don't seem to have that describe
see that's so huge when you look at the
the the New Orleans Saints you know
their defense are struggling a little
bit they stop there you have the you got
number one in a rush 28 in the pass
that's such a large number right a home
the Rams they got a great deal i bad
secondary you look at Kansas City there
are scoring people look at Jacksonville
great defense their offense is pretty
much at a snail's pace um you know Green
Bay you look at their defense they're
young they use their first they use
their first and second last year first
to draft corners you don't draft that
many corners that much unless you need
help right I mean I can go on and on
about teams that the discrepancy is
night and day on the defense and offense
and the teams that can basically is in
2018 the football season is saying who
can ask if I can I'll score you and
hopefully make you make some mistakes on
defense will win the game and I said New
Orleans thank Steve Smith senior NFL
Network right here on the Rich Eisen
show when you look at the Packers
offensively what do you see when you see
this scheme because we had Greg Jennings
in here last week and he kind of put it
on blast what do you see Steve I I mean
first of all you got the ultimate
Mulligan you got the guy Aaron Rodgers
but let's be honest when you talk about
Aaron Rodgers who's behind them so you
eat for the last couple of years they
get it tight in that you take your help
I'm going to barely use them right and
when I was talking about Sunday when
when I talked about the Green Bay
Packers of Brett Farr you can talk about
the great supporting cast that he had
marcha merit ID and Bubba Franks
then you got Donald Driver right you had
Greg Jennings a little bit you have all
the Antonio Freeman you had all these
guys sterling I mean I was Shannon
Sharpe there's a number of guys a mod
green just all these different guys when
you talk about the Green Bay Packers now
you say Aaron Rodgers maybe it's Randall
Cobb maybe it's a departed Jordy Nelson
but there's no guys on there when you
look down their chart you go oh we gotta
watch out for that guy you gotta watch
off a guy what do we talk about
ana rajesh makes those guys better you
got to get a supporting castle it's just
not gonna work out they're no longer the
best team in the NFC North they are so
now let's talk about a couple of your
former teams here starting with the
Ravens three losses in a row
Ian Rapoport came on game day morning
after you signed off on Good Morning
football weekend Steve and said that
John Harbaugh is on the hot seat then
they went out and lost to the Steelers
he said I deserved hot seat do you think
for John in Baltimore well whether it's
deserved deserved or not somebody hit
that uh seat warmer and he's on that ten
hour road trip from Charlotte in our
road trip from Charlotte to Disney World
Florida and it's hot right now I mean he
is sweat and got a sweater on everything
he even took his shirt off he's got a
scarf scarf all it is human because you
got to understand they got a new GM
that's going to take over air guitar sir
you guys you knew some Hall of Famers
great it's this time moving on right you
look at this offense they gotta they
changed offense they changed quarterback
coach they change this thing's defense
coordinator defense coordinator re
retires and what 9 days later he's our
new office defensive coordinator for
Tennessee Titans where they moved him
out right they spend money they got some
great guys but they're not getting in a
win column right so at some point it's
not the players they drafted a
quarterback
it's not the players and I'm not saying
this john harbaugh but time is coming up
and this is a team and a city that
expects playoffs expects to win and they
keep coming up short something has to
change there's something wrong with
Flacco or is it just his time is it just
time Steve I think just like in New York
it's not necessarily something always
wrong with a guy sometimes it just
happens that's the way ball is right it
just happens we all have to leave
whether they assure you out they revoke
your access card or it just an injury
happens or it's just time and
unfortunately at some point it's gonna
be time for Joe and it looks like it's
coming up sooner than later for coach
Harbaugh and I think coach our balls are
great coach but when you don't make the
playoffs with a team that you expect to
make the playoffs this isn't a Cleveland
Brown system a systematic bangles we're
below average it's accept it Baltimore
they don't accept below average I mean
it's a four in five and then the
Steelers come in and James Conner looks
as great as any running back has looked
in the NFL and that's period end of
story I mean there's the numbers to back
it up the eye test as well are they
better with him than levy on bail in
Pittsburgh Steve what do you think I
mean he's doing a great job but listen
maybe I'll belt lady on bail is sitting
out doing his deal because at the end of
the day what they offer lady on bail
some people sitting at sitting in
sitting in their minivans and in their
nice cars or bad cars whatever way you
want to scale it they say just take the
money well listen where they offered him
a two-year deal that is an 18-month
rental lady i bel understands what do we
always say about running backs what
everybody said about AP oh he's over the
hill don't sign a TS 33 years old lady
I'll bail is 28 29 do you think that
Le'Veon Bell is gonna get paid a lot of
money at 30 years old then he would at
28 29 no so he's saying I
no my value I'm not gonna settle because
I understand this is my last and only
payday I don't blame her
that's part of the that's part of it he
wants to take care of family he wants to
maximize his value because he knows at
some point how about this Green Bay
Packers there running back was Eddie
Lacy what the hell is a teal s you doing
right now where's he at at the crib okay
CJ CJ and Chris Johnson yeah I was Chris
Johnson where's he at at the house these
are the house right there's a number of
running backs that are sitting at the
house right now
lady lady our Bell understands that when
he submits his house right now
that's the issue exactly he is but guess
what I know I'm messing my wife my wife
isn't listening so hey getting a
contract in a Cell just like Marik's
just gotta convince one person like you
a few more minutes later and yes just
like me I'll kick my covers so I'm not
completely it's the you me both sir and
how far do you think the Panthers can go
here Steve they really look recast on
offense right how far do you think they
can go well a couple of weeks ago I said
they need to play four quarters of
football they've done that they kind of
messed up in the third quarter but um
they're looking really good and nor this
really has this offense going
you know anybody's taught me all he's
revamped the offense North hasn't
revamped it North has taken his system
that was already implemented I know this
system this system it was Chuck was came
from where Ron's was a tight end coach
who and nor was the head coach out of
San Diego then Mike Shula became when
she went off to Cleveland my sure
maintained the offense and then now Norv
is their originator norm knows the X's
and O's he knows it so why not have the
guy who originated this offense he's
implementing his
his deal on there he's doing a great job
a lot of misdirection but the thing is
that's interesting with the Carolina
Panthers in New Orleans Saints is the
NFC South they're doing well but how is
it gonna go when these two heavyweights
go at it four to one home game on one
away cake
that's what I'm looking for and then
you'll know who's gonna be at the top of
the leaderboard for the NFC South is it
New Orleans Saints Carolina Panthers
it's gonna be a great game week 15 and
17 do you think you're there in
Charlotte you know the your organization
you think the change in ownership is
given sort of a little bit of wind at
the backs here a little different I'm
not sure I know I know mr. toppers is
gonna implement some things but um you
know this football team was a good
football team already now I know he has
allowed some players agreed who they got
at a bargain who was who's doing a
phenomenal job back there but I think
years you will see the imprint and the
fingerprint of David Harper on this
organization over a period of time he
hasn't even got started yet so it's
pretty exciting but we're living I live
in the south and sometimes change is not
always accepted um easily but they will
see the fan base we'll see over time
it'll be for the better
all right last one for you Steve Smith
best team in the NFL is through nine
weeks is best team NFC I would have to
go to New Orleans Saints AFC I think
it's a photo finish between New England
and Kansas City I like Kansas City
because it's like they're like a
traveling track meet men and boys just
go they do they really do and how about
New England sticking cordarrelle
Patterson back there did you ever play
around back even in an emergency Steve
you ever do that yeah I did that in
college didn't work out too well state
of our machine he's running downhill
into the end zone it was unbelievable
yes also I mean what Bill Belichick does
is is unbelievable what Tom Brady does
unbelievable and Josh McDaniels
hopefully Josh McDaniels
will not have to save success or lack of
success that mac patricia is having in
detroit so when he gets his opportunity
he'll be better but I mean you got time
terrific
40 90 55 years old playing quarterback
and out there dropping downs and you got
Nate Peterman out there playing for the
other team and Blake bortles making 18
million dollars to hand it off to a
whole bunch of plethora running backs
great seen you in London Steve loved
watching you on the network love it love
it love it thanks for calling thank you
we'll see you soon take care
that's Steve Smith senior the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience